turkey as President says he's
considering launching a ground operation
in Northern Syria on Monday several
Rockets fired from Syria struck the
District of carcamis in southern turkey
three people were killed including a
child no one has claimed responsibility
well the attack followed a number of
Turkish airstrikes in Northern Syria and
Iraq the defense Ministry says it was
targeting armed groups that turkey a
blames for a bomb attack in Istanbul
last week so strikes hit bases of the
outlawed Kurdistan Workers Party also
known as the pkk
let's go straight to cinem kasolu who is
live in carcamus which is along the
Turkish Syrian border said I'm good to
see you what is the latest situation on
the ground today
Marlene although the air campaign
conducted by the Turkish Armed Forces
targeting several uh ypg and pkk
positions is over Tit for Tat
continuance we are in carcom it's a
border District of gaziantep and we are
nearly 400 or 500 meters from the border
and since we arrived here we can still
hear some shelling artillery shelling
from both sides against each other as a
true care conducted the operation the
ypg groups pyd representatives and the
pkp has been claiming that trucia
targeted their civilian areas and that's
why they are shelling inside Turkish
borders and as a retaliation and turkey
side retaliers as well now I'm standing
in front of a school that was hit by two
rockets yesterday I will just move aside
so that you can see the place this is
the Eastern side of the building and a
rocket hit the building and there was a
science laboratory inside which is
totally damaged right now inside the
school there are some other rooms that
have been damaged and we have been
speaking to students and people who are
working in the school they are telling
us how they were afraid the school was
also hit on the other side
on its Other Side by Rockets fired from
uh from from the border side and another
nearby school was also hit and 22 year
old teacher lost their life in the other
school now the town is a little bit
quiet as as the residents are preparing
for two funerals one funeral is a
five-year-old boy who lost his life
inside his own while he was playing on
his bicycle his house is nearly 200
meters from where I stand also I know
their funeral is going to be held in
another district
for the teacher who lost her life who
lost her life so people are saying that
they are terrified and they are not
happy that these shellings are
continuing and
the Kurdish side and turkey side is very
close to each other but Turkish
authorities claim these shellings are
coming from einel arap kobane which
turkey considers the base of the ypg and
the outboard Kurdistan Workers Party
apparently they did for that situation
is to continue for a while thank you for
that speaking to us which is on the
turkey a Syria border